yupikai movie lovers i'm jan
and in this video i'm revealing all the
super cool easter eggs and details
hidden in we can be heroes
netflix's shark boy and lava girl sequel
including a secret cameo from the real
original shark boy just before we begin
many thanks the sponsor of this video
raid shadow legends
obviously spoilers ahead so take care
when it comes to breakfast time missy is
a fan of great white bite cereal
as max was in the original movie in fact
you can see several packs of the shark
inspired cereal in the moreno family's
kitchen
after they're captured by the aliens the
heroics can't stop bickering and
fighting amongst themselves
why don't you cheer us up by singing one
of those little songs you sing so well
sharkboy here miracle guy is mocking
sharkboy about the lullaby he sang in
the first film to help max fall asleep
so he could dream a solution to the
problems
close your eyes shut your mouth dream a
dream and get us out
although shark boys song was initially
successful it
actually ended up giving max nightmares
while the original lava girl taylor
dooley is back to play the adult version
of her character
taylor lautner doesn't return a shark
boy instead adult shark boy
is a non-speaking character played by a
mask wearing jj dashnaw who is the stunt
coordinator for both the sequel and the
first film
there are some awesome easter eggs to
the original movie in missy's bedroom
look carefully at her bedside table and
in the corner you'll spot the first of
two children's novels that were
co-written by the film's director robert
rodriguez and published around the time
of the movie's release in 2005.
there's the daydreamer which tells the
film's story from lava girl and shark
boy's point of view
and i suspect the book below that is
returned to planet drool the second in
the shark boy and lava girl series
also on missy's nightstand is her heroic
themed alarm clock and a fun detail here
is that while the other superheroes are
doing the hard work of holding up the
clock
miracle guy is just standing there
posing which given that he stops to take
a photo during the alien invasion at the
start of the movie
seems like a perfect reflection of
reality selfie from my socials while i
stop this thing
in the sequel missy's bedroom is space
themed with planets stalls and moons on
her bed head and walls and
constellations on this fabric
which is just like in the first film
where max's bedroom
also had a cosmic theme with mobiles of
the solar system moons stars and
galaxies on the wall
and stickers of planets on his bed frame
and both lead characters also wear
space-themed pajamas
max has planets on his while missy has
stars on hers
and she also has stars on the black
trousers she wears throughout the film
after sneaking on board an
extraterrestrial supply ship
missy and her super parents desperately
try to get away from the aliens about to
attack them
but it's more difficult to fly this ship
than simply pressing the green for go
button
is a send up of the scene in the
original movie where hitting the green
go button was all max had to do to blast
off in his shark-shaped rocket
how do you fly it you don't know that's
sort of an old problem
you pascal and when guppy puts on a pair
of blue sunglasses during the kids
training session
i couldn't help but think of her
father's blue 3d shark-shaped glasses in
the previous movie
vivian blair who plays guppy was
actually given the glasses as it was so
bright filming outside that she couldn't
stop squinting
but then the filmmakers decided she
looked so cool that they made them part
of her character's costume whenever she
went into a shark frenzy
guppy listen to me shark frenzy
and that behavior is another thing she
has in common with her dad
[Music]
all of ojo's tablet pictures were
actually drawn on set during the filming
of those scenes by rhiannon rodriguez
daughter of director robert rodriguez
as for the squiggle monsters the
filmmakers wanted them to look like a
child had created them with their own
pen
as they wanted to illustrate the idea
that the pen is always mightier than the
sword
the fact that oho's drawings come to
life also reminds me of how the
imaginary worlds and superheroes max
doodles and writes about in his dream
journal
also come to life in the first movie
when guppy demonstrates her powers for
missy the pint-sized superhero takes a
gulp of water then spits out a liquid
shark which she moves into a position
that's a clear hat tip to the theatrical
poster for the 1975 shark infested
blockbuster jaws
place it in the film as slo-mo
desperately tries to outrun the aliens
chasing him
acapella stopped singing the iconic
theme to the oscar-winning movie
chariots of fire whose tale of british
athletes vying for the 1924 olympics
famously featured several slo-mo running
sequences
set to composer vangelis's legendary
score
by the way in order to give acapella's
voice an extra otherworldly effect
[Music]
when she sings the higher notes the
filmmakers blended together the voice of
actress loses blossom who plays acapella
with the voice of american idol singer
hayley reinhart who plays her mother mrs
fox
sharkboy and lava girl's daughter guppy
is named after a type of small tropical
fish
which is perfect for her character as
she's both little and has water-related
powers
continuing the aquatic theme on her
t-shirt there's a picture of a fish
and her clothes and water bottle are
blue pink and purple which are the
colours of her parents
as for the rainbow on guppy's necklace
that's a subtle symbol at the start of
the film that she and her fellow super
kids are humanity's hope for a better
world
which is exactly what ocho tells them at
the end of the movie
while missy's starry clothing is a shout
out to the first movie
it also reflects the fact she's the real
star of the new team
as without her inspiring them to work
together they'd be in the same mess as
their bickering parents
but missy's not only at the heart of the
new heroics she's also a character with
a loss of heart
which could be why the film's costume
designer chose to put some subtle little
hearts on her outfit
from her t-shirt to a heart-shaped
necklace
like many of the other kids whose
clothing signals their powers
wheels has a w style symbol on his shirt
which suitably enough
also looks a little like jagged skid
marks
taylor lautner may have skipped the
sequel but two of the other original
shark boys do return
look out for the pilot of the helicopter
during the heroics big battle scene
that pilot is racer rodriguez who played
a young shark boy in the previous film
in fact racer truly is the original
sharkboy
because as a seven-year-old child he
actually created the character of
sharkboy when he was playing a game of
fish vs shark with his dad
robert rodriguez in the family pool and
while ray's a new sequel his brother
rebel who played the five-year-old
sharkboy in the first movie wrote the
music for the sequel
and as a rodriguez family in joke at the
end of the film when aha revealed as the
film's alien spaceship sets were in fact
designed by rogue rodriguez another of
the director's kids
by the way i've got another video that
reveals all the clues that pointed to
the movie's big twist
there'll be a link to that at the end of
this video and in the description below
another rodriguez sibling rhiannon is
the voice of missy's alarm clock at the
start of the movie singing wake up
sleepyhead and a little shout out to
max's rocket alarm in the first film
which displays the words wake up max
when the alarm goes off
[Applause]
rhiannon was also the inspiration of the
film's lead character whose name missy
is actually rhiannon's nickname
and whose initials were intended to
reflect the alliteration in rhiannon's
name too
and of course that also fits very nicely
with the world of comic book superheroes
especially marvel ones whose names often
rely on alliteration
and if you're looking for more super
powered fun to entertain yourself over
the holidays and new year you should
check out raid shadow legends
it's an epic fantasy gaming experience
with badass champions tough bosses and
millions of other players you can pit
yourself against
set amid an epic struggle that's raged
for thousands of years
you'll fight noble kings and dark
wizards uncover prophecies curses and
betrayals and meets scores of warring
factions
use the links below to download raid to
your mobile phone or pc
one of the best things about raid is the
16 awesome factions which include lizard
men
banner lords undead hordes and many more
and each faction has its own set of
unique champions you can collect
i'm a fan of the dwarves and high elves
factions as they have some awesome
champions such as a legendary arbiter
a servant of the goddess of light among
the dwarvish champions are like beard or
felhammer who has an awesome protection
ability that was bestowed on him by fae
spirits of the forest
his paranoia skill also gives him great
counter attack abilities and stamina
making him an amazing champion for
farming campaigns
and just in time for the holidays and
new year raid have launched their
biggest ever update with the doom tower
it's a giant tower with 120 floors a
bunch of secret challenge rooms and 12
incredible new bosses to take on
on top of that they're releasing 14
badass new
champions and a ton of holiday events
and tournaments
it's a perfect moment to start playing
and here's the best part
if you sign up today you'll get a stack
of free goodies and a super special
champion call bulwark to get you started
in the doom tower
he's a super strong dwarf who'll wear
down the enemy with his discipline and
incredibly tough defensive skills
keeping you in the game much longer
so to get a huge head start in raid hit
the link in the description below and if
you're a new player you'll get your void
champion bulwark
an xp booster energy refills and an
ancient
shard all completely free after you've
installed the game you'll find all of
these rewards and treasure in your inbox
here
don't forget you can only get these
bonuses by clicking on the links below
the offer runs for the next 30 days only
so don't delay and install raid shadow
legends today
now what do you think about the shark
boy and lava girl sequel and did you
notice any other cool details in the
film
let me know in the